what if i told you 30 mortgage rates  will very soon hit 10 yes 10 now some of  you may be saying pat that'll never  happen but remember just two years ago  you and i were paying 2.20 cents per  gallon of gas and how much did you pay  for gas lately 450 550 if you're in  california seven dollars 10  coming very soon i'm hosting a real  estate crash webinar next tuesday the  19th at 5 30 p.m eastern standard time  if you haven't yet registered for the  webinar click on the link above or below  join me for one hour presentation at the  end i'll give you all the data points  all the links free pdf to show you why i  believe this is going to be happening to  real estate so if you haven't registered  yet click on the link above or below put  it in your calendar i'll see you next  tuesday 5 30 pm the 19th take care bye